all right so we've been speculating for
a while that as Donald Trump continues
to not suffer consequences from
different events that take place during
his presidency he's going to become more
and more authoritarian the latest of
course was his acquittal in impeachment
and we anticipated that he would become
even more unhinged and authoritarian if
Donald Trump were to be reelected in
November he will become even more
authoritarian and unhinged and acting
unilaterally and why wouldn't he right
from the start of the Moller probe we
said this is not going to remove him and
Trump got out of it
yeah sure some of his friends went to
prison he's trying to reduce for how
long of course as we see with the Roger
stone case but why wouldn't he become
more authoritarian he got away with it
the 25th amendment many argue should be
used to remove a president that is
increasingly unfit temperamentally
cognitively to be President of the
United States doesn't matter it's not
going to remove Donald Trump we now saw
impeachment acquittal Trump getting away
with it once again so if you are Trump
why don't you do whatever you want
because they got they can't touch you it
really seems as though he is indeed
Teflon Don talking about pardons
possibly now we'll get to that a little
bit later
remember that Donald Trump so to give
you the the reminder Roger stone from
associate was convicted and the
recommendation from prosecutors was for
seven to nine years in prison Donald
Trump flipped out tweeted yesterday we
did a story about Trump's tweet which
subsequently was followed up by the
Justice Department backtracking and
saying well we no longer recommend seven
to nine years we just recommend some
prison time this immediately led to the
resignation of multiple prosecutors on
the case who were disgusted with the way
in which this was being handled and then
yesterday Donald Trump gave one of these
gongshow press conferences and there is
so much to look at here a lot of it
related to Donald Trump's incipient
authoritarian as
the question asked of Trump will you
pardon Roger stone Trump says I'm not
ready to say yet but there's lots of
people who by the way haven't been
charged with any crimes who in Trump's
mind are worse than stone listen to the
specific words Trump is using here and
then we'll discuss I don't want to say
that yet but I tell you what people were
hurt viciously and badly by these
corrupt people and I want to thank if
you look at what happened I want to
thank the Justice Department for seeing
this this horrible thing and I didn't
speak to them by the way just so you
understand
they saw the horribleness of a nine year
sentence for doing nothing
you have murderers and drug addicts
it'll get nine years nine years for
doing something that nobody even can
define what he did the journal buddy
said he put out a tweet and the tweet
you based it on that we have killers we
have murderers all over the place
nothing happens and then they put a man
in jail and destroy his life his family
his wife his children nine years in jail
it's a disgrace
in the meantime Comey walks around
making book deals the people that
launched the scam investigation and what
they did is a disgrace and hopefully
it'll be treated fairly everything else
would be treated so there is so much
here first of all notice that Trump said
I didn't talk to the Justice Department
now we don't know if that's true or not
Trump lies all the time he may have
spoken to the Justice Department he may
have spoken to the Justice Department
indirectly but Trump publicly tweeted
his displeasure with the recommendation
of seven to nine years in prison for
Roger stone the Justice Department is
monitoring Trump's tweets bill Barr
knows what it is that Donald Trump wants
so this idea that even if true is a mere
irrelevant technicality that Trump
didn't talk to the Justice Department he
slips that in there then Trump says
stone shouldn't get nine years in prison
because James Comey isn't in prison now
that's not an argument I believe most of
our audience would understand that it is
not a legal argument it is not an
ethical argument it's not an American
argument
to say stone who's been convicted
shouldn't get nine years because the FBI
director Trump fired to obstruct the
Russia probe isn't currently imprisoned
Comey has not been charged with anything
never mind convicted there is there are
a few things less American than
suggesting stone sentence should be
lower because someone who's not been
even legally formally accused of a crime
is not currently in prison then Trump
was asked and this is very interesting
did you learn a lesson from impeachment
and Trump says yeah I did Democrats are
absolutely terrible check it out the
Republicans have said they hoped you
would learn a lesson from impeachment
what lesson did you learn from
impeachment that the Democrats are
crooked they've got a lot of crooked
things going that they're vicious that
they shouldn't have brought impeachment
and even had that by all numbers are ten
points higher because of fake news like
NBC which reports the news very
inaccurately probably more inaccurately
than CNN if that's possible
MSDN see and you're a mess and if you
take a look at NBC now I think they're
among the most dishonest reporters of
the news okay thank you very much
everybody
now this actually is logical again the
molar probe Trump gets out scot-free
believes it's an exoneration even though
it's not 25th amendment stuff isn't
going to touch him impeachment he gets
acquitted he's gotten away with
pardoning people what all of this stuff
right yeah what Trump learned from all
of these things including impeachment is
there's a lot of people trying to do
stuff to me they're failing I feel like
it's an exoneration and they must be bad
people because it's all felt like a huge
waste of time now by the way this issue
of continuing through our tour of
authoritarianism through Donald Trump's
mind despite saying yesterday that he
did not talk to the Justice Department
here he is in the last couple of days
saying if he wanted to talk to the
Justice Department and tell them what to
do about Roger stone sentence he
absolutely would have the legal right to
do it check it out I thought it was
ridiculous that ya thought of that no I
didn't speak to the
I'd be able to do it if I wanted I have
the absolute right to do it I stay out
of things to a degree that people
wouldn't believe what I didn't speak to
him I thought the recommendation was
ridiculous
I thought the whole prosecution was
ridiculous and I look at others that
haven't been prosecuted or I don't know
where it is now but when you see that I
thought it was an insult to our country
and again he's probably right he
probably would be able to get away with
that because he gets away with
everything and once again comparing
Roger stone to people not indicted not
prosecuted this is a completely
unamerican way to evaluate a sentence
someone not charged with a crime is free
so stone shouldn't get 7 to 9 years
because he's on Trump's side politically
this is you know I try on this program
we don't want to be hyperbolic but we
don't want to understate things either
this is one of the most fundamentally
unamerican ideas that we've heard from
Donald Trump so far and if allowed to
continue for a second term this is
exactly the type of thinking that
escalated by being a sitting duck
by feeling exonerated from the Muller
probe from impeachment so on and so
forth this can lead to a very I will say
an even more dangerous Donald Trump in
office which is why we have one recourse
we have one option we have one path to
his removal you all know what it is I
won't even say it but it takes place in
November make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on Instagram for more
coverage of this and other stories at
david pakman show and while you're on
Instagram follow me at David Pakman this
episode is sponsored by blue chew one of
the things I make a priority on the show
is not to perpetuate stigma for things
that don't deserve it we've talked about
mental health we've talked about many
things where we should all just be
respectful adults period and we would be
better off and blue two can increase
performance and give you that extra
confidence you may be looking for blue
to calm blue like the color blue is the
first chewable with this
same fda-approved ingredient as in
Viagra and Cialis it can be taken day or
night even on a full stomach since it's
chewable it works twice as fast as a
pill whenever the opportunity arises
blue Chu is prescribed online by
licensed doctors you don't have to go to
a doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet package they're
made in the USA and since blue 2
prepares and ships direct it's cheaper
than a pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
com get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show